- I don't know, why
does my mind go to drugs
immediately with all of these?
K-pop is a drug.
(upbeat music)
I know that K-pop is
loud and wild and fun.
Occasionally I will turn on the
K-pop radio station on Spotify.
- I've watched a couple of Big Bang videos
in like junior high.
- I know it's wildly popular in Korea.
I've never heard of K-pop slang before.
So this should be a learning experience.
- Pretty confident that
I know zero K-pop slang.
- Well was Gangnam
Style technically K-pop,
or, that's literally all I know.
- Bias.
Um, this is a real word.
So that's why I'm struggling.
- Maybe this is like a sick beat
in K-pop.
Like, man that bias was so sick.
- Maybe it's like when you're
listening to a new song
by a K-pop group, and you
know what kind of music
they do already, so your bias is like,
you already know how the music's gonna be.
- I'm gonna say like, hater?
If someone's showing bias they could
not be a fan of something else.
- [Man] Bias.
Your favorite member of a K-pop group.
- That makes a lot of sense.
I mean it does have to do with
the English definition of bias.
- That is amazing.
I will be incorporating that
into my everyday vocabulary.
- Visual.
Visual probably means like
who's the hottest person
of the group, I would say.
- Who's your visual of the group?
Oh, okay, sure.
The hottest member of a K-pop group.
- A visual is when you are swayed to like
a new song more by the dance
moves in the music video
than the music itself.
- Attractive?
Like hot?
Blah blah blah is super visual.
- [Man] Visual is the member
who's considered the most
attractive by the ideal
set of beauty standards.
- Isn't that how most
boy bands and girl groups
are like put together?
There's always that one person.
- Hi-touch.
Oh man.
A song that spans the
reach of many generations.
- Maybe it's like you wave to somebody,
and then you give them a hug,
or someone super super tall
and you like tap them on the
head, 'cause you're tall.
- Hi-touch I feel like just
feels like top of the line,
when like a group member
does something cool,
you're like, that was so hi-touch!
- This is when a K-pop band reaches you
very deep inside of yourself.
Like you really have a lot of feelings.
I was hi-touched by (laughs) BTS.
(cheering)
- [Man] A fan service where
K-pop idols stand up with
their hands out and fans line
up to give them a high five.
- They stand up, they go like this, right?
And they like, oh yeah, I totally got it.
- Trash.
Trash is the member of
the K-pop band that's like
they're just the worst
in every way possible.
- The not good K-pop bands.
- Man,
that song trashed.
Meaning, it sucked.
- A song that you secretly like
that other people hate.
- When you have an unhealthy obsession
with a particular group,
and you acknowledge it.
So like, I'm trashed with BTS?
- [Group Of Men] Oh yeah!
- Taylor Swift trash.
(people cheering)
- K-pop slang is fun, I
learned so many new words now.
- It is creative, it knows no bounds,
and I think I'm gonna start using it.
- I guess I wasn't expecting real words.
I don't know what I was expecting.
- They're pretty close
to the actual definition,
I was expecting a lot
more like weird words.
Hey, you're trash.
- Hi-touch is actually
just really funny to me.
(playful music)